>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
John Cole:
>> Good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole, I'm the Director
for the Center for the Book
which is the reading and literacy
promotion arm of the library
and we promote books
in reading and literacy
in every way we can think of.
And we work around the
country actually with a system
of states Centers for the Book
and every state that does work,
promotion work in the states often
through literacy festivals
and book festivals.
We also have reading
promotion partners.
We also play here at the library,
a major role in the National
Book Festival which I hope most
of you know and participate in.
And the Books and Beyond series
which you are attending today
is our series of noon time talks
about writers who have new
books that relate in some way
to the Library of Congress
and does this one every relate
to the Library of Congress.
There's lots of different ways.
And we're going to enjoy not
only quite a tale but also,
really kind of a revelation
of coincidences
that are speaker will talk about
relating to the name Urschel.
And that's one that I'm going
to leave our speaker to get into
but I want to tell you a little
bit about what will happen.
Our, Joe will speak for 30 to 40
minutes with his presentation.
We'll have time for
questions and answers
and then we will have
a book signing.
All of these programs are filmed
for the Library of Congress website.
So I will ask you to turn
off all things electronic
and we will proceed
with the program.
Joe Urschel is the
Executive Director of NOW,
currently of the National
Law Enforcement Museum
which will be built
in, which will be built
in Washington D.C. I
knew Joe, I first met him
when he was executive
director of the museum.
And I read a little bit
about him last night
and he merely was really one
of the founders of the museum.
And now has moved on in this area.
He's the former managing editor
of USA Today where he also served
as a senior correspondent columnist.
He has worked for the
Detroit Free Press
as a reporter, critic and editor.
And he has loads and loads
of journalism honors.
Not only do I want you to make
sure you turn off your electronic
devices, but I want to tell
you a couple of other things.
We do have on the table when
you go out to the signing area,
a couple of the Center
for the book publications
which includes the latest issue of
the Library of Congress magazine,
LQM which on of all
things, the Joy of Reading.
And we worked hard with the
communications office to get this
out in time for the last
book festival and we made it.
And it's still right now
is the most current issue.
So I want you to pick
up a copy if you can.
You'll learn about what the
library does throughout the library
to promote books and reading.
Secondly, the Center for the
Book has just produced as part
of the Literacy Awards
program, our best practices
that really describe the
award winners for this year.
And this excellent publication
does describe the organizations.
We gave three.
This program is supported by David
Rubenstein and it's the third year
of the five year grant program.
And we give cash awards and
also best practice awards.
And this year we recognize 17
organizations from around the world.
So I almost forgot to tell
you about that, but I want you
to have a chance to pick that
up before Mr. Urschel starts.
But he's agreed to let
me start in one way.
I mentioned that most of the
Books and Beyonds connection
with the Library of Congress, a lot
of them are based on the collections
of the library where
the research was done.
Others are established because
of a project that the Library
of Congress has developed
or a publication.
And we sponsor these programs for
really, many of the new Library
of Congress publications.
We are also, there's a
special family connection here
in this instance.
Donna Urschel who does
such a wonderful job
in our communications
office is Joe's wife.
But also there's a story I'm going
to read about how he first thought
up this book and this is another
Library of Congress connection.
And this is reading from the
author's note just a little bit.
This is Joe speaking.
In 1982, shortly after I
moved to Washington D.C.,
I went to visit the Library of
Congress' Jefferson building.
It doesn't mention
Donna being along but,
one of the city's most gorgeous
landmarks which contains,
as it said, the greatest collection
of knowledge in the world.
Amen. The Library of Congress had
just recently converted its fame
collection cataloging system
in semicolon, semi-parenthesis.
The one J. Edgar Hoover,
a character in this,
had learned during his brief
[inaudible] there as a clerk earlier
in his career, in parenthesis,
then converted
into a searchable computerized
database,
something that was quite novel
and innovative at the time.
Out of curiosity, I went to the
keyboard and typed in my last name.
A simple Google search today
would now reveal hundreds of hits,
but back then in the early
days of the digital revolution,
the LOC's computer index
turned up only one,
Charles Urschel, kidnapping victim.
And there was one book in
which he was noted prominently.
It was E.E. Kirkpatrick's
firsthand account, Crime's Paradise.
The authentic inside story
of the Urschel kidnapping,
published in 1934.
I immediately requested the book.
And when the librarian
pulled it from the stacks,
I sat in LOCs stately reading
room and read it cover to cover.
Let me introduce Joe Urschel
to continue the story, Joe.
[ Applause & Silence ]
Joe Urschel:
>> So imagine my surprise
when this name pops up
and I know nothing about the fellow.
I thought I knew that
all of the Urschels
in the country were related,
I of course was wrong.
But I was just transfixed by the
idea that I didn't know anything
about this guy who shared my
last name and was so instrumental
in this landmark crime and landmark
crime investigation and prosecution.
I knew a lot about J. Edgar Hoover,
one of the other main characters.
I thought I knew a lot
about Machine Gun Kelly,
the leader of the criminal gang
that perpetrates the kidnapping.
But the central character of the
story, the true hero was kind
of lost to history and
that was Charles Urschel.
So I called up my Dad and I said you
know, are we related to this guy,
we've got to be related to him.
And he said, no we're not.
I said, how do you know?
He said, we're just not, I know.
So like any good son I immediately
set out to prove my Dad wrong
and began a little genealogical
research and kept digging
into the origins of the name
and the origins of the family.
And darn, it turned
out we weren't related,
at least not in this country and
not dating back a century or more
into Germany or what is
now the German Republic.
So with that I began
collecting string on this story.
I of course was still transfixed
by the idea of this story
and Kirkpatrick's book which
was written, Kirkpatrick,
it turned out is a player
in this, in the story.
He worked for Charles Urschel
and while Charles was kidnapped,
he had served as the man
who delivered the ransom.
His book was written
but one year afterward
and it didn't get a lot of play.
And it was kind of
subsequently ignored by scholars
who were researching the story.
But it's one of the most
remarkable kidnappings in history.
It produced the largest
manhunt in the history
of American law enforcement
at the time.
The FBI or the Bureau
of Investigation
which had just been
authorized to cross state lines
to catch kidnappers, they were the
only law enforcement agency allowed
to do that.
Crossed 16 state lines and covered
20,000 miles in their effort to run
down Machine Gun Kelly and
his glamourous wife Kathryn.
It resulted in a sensational trial
that was covered daily in the press
by reporters from, not just
reporters from around the country
but around the world as well.
The Europeans were just fascinated
by the criminality of Americans
and heavily reported on the
things that were going here.
The case really launched the FBI.
The FBI would one year later become
the FBI after being just the Bureau
of Investigation of the
Department of Justice.
And it gave the FBI agents
their nickname of G Men.
It resulted in the establishment
of Alcatraz as a federal prison,
basically a penal colony for
the, what they call the vicious
and irredeemable types,
the worst of the worst.
And it sped the passage of
the Federal Crime Bill of 1934
which established a number
of new federal crimes
that the FBI would then
be allowed to prosecute
and greatly expanded the,
their powers and made the crime
of kidnapping punishable by death.
And all of this was made possible by
the cooperation of Charles Urschel,
the man forgotten to history.
The story takes place in 1933 which,
as the title claims
is the year of fear.
It is one of the worst
years, if not the worst years
in American history
since the Civil War.
You have a number of, you
have a confluence of a number
of disastrous elements taking place.
It is the worst year
of the depression,
the depression has lingered
on for about 3 1/2 years
when this is taken place.
And consequently you have
unemployment rates in some cities
that stretch as high as 84%.
Farms are devastated, homes
are being repossessed.
And at the same time
that that's going on,
the Dust Bowl is beginning.
And the Dust Bowl was just a
cataclysmic environmental disaster.
It would pick up dirt in Oklahoma
City where this crime takes place
and blow it all the way into
Newfoundland and out to sea.
It was, the dust was so thick that
it would choke cattle in the fields
and it would blind ships
coming into New York Harbor
and turn the snow red in Maine.
And with all of that going on,
you've got, these are a couple
of pictures from the library's
collection of the effects
of the Dust Bowl, with
all that going
on you've got this incredible sense
of lawlessness that's
spreading through the country.
Basically, big cities out east are
being run and controlled by large
and organized crime gangs.
You know, notoriously
Al Capone is Chicago.
But out West along what was
referred to as the criminal corridor
which stretched from Dallas,
Texas to St. Paul, Minnesota,
you had basically the extensions of
the outlaw gangs of the Wild West.
And these were kind of independent
contractors who would pick up
and form gangs to rob banks or run
liquor or to serve as assassins
for the organized criminals
in the eastern cities
and they were basically
running unimpeded in that area,
because of the cooperation of local
police and the ineffectiveness,
the ineffectiveness and the
lack of a national police force.
There really was no force at the
time that was allowed to cross it,
the county sheriffs shouldn't
really cross county lines in pursuit
and they didn't cross state lines.
And at the time they were only
11 state police forces anyway.
So these guys like Kelly
and his gang would operate
with virtual impunity.
And in a lot of cases
they had the support
of the local population as well.
If you're a farmer and you've
been foreclosed on by the bank,
you don't shed a lot of tears
when somebody robs that bank.
And of course, these
gangsters were pretty good
at self-promotion as well.
A number of them would claim that
when they would rob the bank,
they would tear up the mortgage
notes as well to protect the farmers
from being foreclosed upon.
Doubtful whether they
actually ever did that
but anyway that's what
the story was.
And at the time that
all of this is going on,
prohibition is about to end.
Prohibition ends in 1933 with
the incoming FDR Administration.
And just about the time that FDR
announces that we have nothing
to fear but fear itself, we have
this situation in the country
where lawlessness is
getting worse and worse.
This is the Union Station
in Kansas City,
the site of the Kansas City Massacre
which occurred one month
before the Urschel kidnapping.
And this was thought to
be a, the tipping point
in peoples tolerance
for crime out West.
In this, in this instance Vernon
Miller and two other assassins,
while trying to rescue a captured
prisoner killed four lawmen
and the prisoner himself in
the shootout with machine guns
that lasted about 90
seconds in the middle
of this crowded parking
lot in Kansas City.
And that really put the pressure
on J. Edgar Hoover and his men
to do something about
this criminality
that was sweeping the nation.
Unfortunately, J. Edgar
Hoover at the time is
in a very tenuous position.
He has just escaped a sacking
from the first attorney general
that FDR appoints, a
fellow named Thomas Walsh.
Walsh was a senator from
Montana who had a very long
and bad history with
J. Edgar Hoover.
During the Harding Administration,
Walsh and his associates
were investigating corruption
and the attorney general at the time
instructed Hoover to dig up dirt
on the guys who were
running the investigation.
So Hoover had tried to compromise
Walsh in any way he possibly could.
He opened his mail.
He tailed his family.
He tried to get a woman to
lure him into a hotel room
where he could photographed,
all of this has failed.
However, Thomas Walsh made it
known that once he took office,
he was going to clean house and
that would be the end J. Edgar
Hoover's reign.
Unfortunately, before he could take
office, he was a 76 year old widow.
He gets married in Miami to a Cuban
debutant, boards the train to come
to Washington, but only makes
it as far as to North Carolina.
And so with his death on the
train, Hoover escaped his sacking
and the next attorney
general appointment,
a fellow named Homer Cummings sees
some potential in Hoover and says,
well we're going to hang on to you
but here's what you need to do.
You need to show us something,
you need to, we need some kind
of marquee case that can prove
that we should be the agency
that should police the nation.
And so Hoover immediately sets
out to do any number of things
to launch his career, including
the capture of the prisoner
who was killed Kansas
City's parking lot.
So at this point, he's desperately
looking around for something
that he could make his mark with.
He's failed for 18 months to
solve the Lindbergh kidnapping
which is lingering on and he's
been under a lot of pressure
and been ridiculed for that.
Nevertheless, he, he's always been
a guy who was interested in sort
of furthering the scientific
approach to law enforcement.
So what he does to combat
the scourge of kidnappings
that are taking place,
is setup a hotline.
It's about to be the first crime
hotline that was in the nation.
So on this hotline you can
call and immediately be put
through to the justice
department to report a kidnapping.
Hoover thinking that this gives his
agents an edge, because they can get
to the scene quickly and get control
of the investigation before
the local cops take it over.
Kidnapping at the time was
becoming rampant around the country,
because of the coming advent
of prohibition and the banks,
banks failing in the depression,
there was very little money to rob
in a bank even you could
successfully pull it off.
So that business was falling
out as well as the pending death
of the gin running businesses
which these guys were also
using to make their living.
So they're getting
squeezed on two ends
and they decide well there's one
way we can make money and we find
out who's got it, we kidnap them
and then we hold them for ransom,
release them with the payment, with
the threat that we didn't hurt you
and we won't hurt you as long
as you don't go to the police.
If you do, we'll come
back and kill not only you
but your family as well.
So between 1930 and 1933, there
were an estimated 2000 successful
kidnappings in the United States.
The whole money class
was becoming paranoid.
You had people like Bing
Crosby and Hollywood driving
around in armor plated cars with
Army guards in the front seat.
You had people hiring protection
and the papers are just full
of all of these reports.
So, on the night of July 27,
1933, our hero George Kelly is
about to pull off his kidnapping
with his partner Albert Bates.
Kelly has been a successful gin
runner for most of his life.
Got into the business in high
school, running liquor from Arkansas
over to the dry state of
Tennessee and basically
with several interruptions
in between has been
doing that ever since.
And after a landing in the
federal prison in Leavenworth
where he met a couple of really hard
cases who teach him how to rob banks
and pull him into their
gang when he gets out.
He's been living kind of high on
the hog which is a great pleasure
to his new wife Kathryn Kelly who
is your classic gangster moll.
She's very inquisitive,
very ruthless,
she loves designer clothing,
fancy jewelry, diamonds.
And she's always pushing
George to do more and more,
to be more and more successful.
So on the, on this evening at 11:30
at night, they break into the home
of Charles Urschel, it
should be next up here,
who is one of the most
wealthy oil men in the nation.
And Kathryn has read
his story because his,
his partner has just died and their
fortune has gone to probate court,
so there's a lot of coverage
about just how much money
Charles Urschel has.
And he has a lot of it,
there's no doubt about that.
So she convinces George that
this should be their first mark.
However, Charles Urschel is an
unusual character on his own.
He's an up from the ground sort of,
he grew up on a farm in the Midwest,
hated farming, enlisted in
the Army in World War I.
Comes out and just decides he's
not going to go back to the farm
and picks up his belongings, takes
off for Oklahoma and Texas to see
if he can make it in the oil
business which he eventually does
by teaming up with a partner, a guy
who later becomes known as the king
of the wildcatters with the
appropriate name of Tom Slick.
So this Slick-Urschel oil company
has just about got control of all
of the land stakes in Oklahoma
and Texas and when Tom dies,
all of that stuff is
in the newspapers
which Kathryn read assiduously.
So they tracked down Urschel's
home and at 11:30 at night,
Kelly and Bates kick in the screen
door and confront two couples
who are playing bridge on
their sun porch which is
in the back of this house.
Kelly's got a machine gun and
Bates has a 45 and they look
at the startled couples and George
realizes he hasn't done quite enough
research because he doesn't
know which one is Urschel.
So he waves his gun around and
says okay we've come for Urschel,
which one's Urschel and
neither guy stands up.
So he says, all right we'll take you
both and then so they throw the two
of them in the back to their car,
they speed off into the night.
Kelly finally gets the idea
that he can ID these guys
by taking the money out of
their wallets and looking
at their IDs which he does.
And he discovers that he's also
got Walter Jerrod in the car.
He doesn't realize that Walter
Jerrod is also an oil millionaire
but he kicks him out of the car,
gives him $10 for a cab ride back
home and takes off with Urschel.
Pulls over to the side of the road,
tapes his eyes shut, plugs his ears,
tapes those shut and for the next
8 days Urschel is basically blind
and somewhat deaf.
They spirit him off to Kathryn
Kelly's father-in-law's farm outside
of Dallas, Texas in Wise
County where they hold him
for the next 8 days and force him
to write a number of ransom notes.
However, the entire time
Urschel is held in captivity,
he's collecting notes
about where he is
by strategically asking questions,
making notes of what's going on
and he, he's basically the oil
company's chief accountant.
But I guess now you'll call
him a chief financial officer,
so he's got a great mind for details
and he doesn't forget anything.
So he figures he's on a farm, he
figures out how many buildings are
on the farm and how big
it is, he knows what kind
of animals are there, he
counts the number of animals,
he knows what the water tastes
like, what the well sounds
like when you pull
water out from it.
He notes the name of the
postman that comes every day,
he knows the name of the
local prostitute that one
of the captures is talking about.
And he also notes that a plane
goes overhead every day at 9:30 am
and at 5:30 pm going the
other direction, every day
but one and he notes that day.
And he's also leaving his
fingerprints strategically
around any place that he can.
So, when he is finally
released, he goes back home.
Of course the authorities
have already been alerted
because his wife Bernice,
within minutes
of his abduction calls J.
Edgar Hoover's hotline.
And it rings at the justice
department, the operator there says,
I'll put you through to
Mr. Hoover immediately.
Hoover has had a line run
all the way to his house.
He's in bed sleeping and he
takes a call from Bernice
at what was then 1:30 am here.
And she says, this
is Bernie Urschel,
I'd like to report a kidnapping.
And he says, this J.
Edgar Hoover Mrs. Urschel,
tell me everything you can.
So when Urschel returns
to his house,
the front yard is loaded with media.
It's got news reel photographers,
newspaper photographers, reporters,
sound men and of course a number
of law enforcement officers.
He goes inside and subsequently
is debriefed by one of the agents
that Hoover has sent down
to run this investigation.
And after talking for 2 1/2 hours,
the FBI or the Bureau's agent says,
well you know, I thought this was
going to be like finding a needle
in a haystack but this is
a pretty small haystack.
So they subsequently get in a plane,
one of the oil company's planes,
they fly low over the area
where they triangulated the airplane
crossings and they look down
and Urschel has drawn a
map of what it looks like
and lo and behold there it is.
So they decided to stage a raid
and Urschel insists that he be
in the front car of the rating party
with a sawed off shotgun
seeking justice.
So this story isn't just
about this particular crime,
but it's also about the power of
publicity and this is kind of an era
where the mass media
is being born as well.
I have huge regional newspapers,
the first radio news broadcast
has just started, NBCs.
And along with the creation of
the mass media is the creation
of the organizations that
try to manipulate the media.
And no one was better at
it than J. Edgar Hoover.
So all along during this case Hoover
is managing the message and building
out the reputations of his agents
as they chase Kelly and his wife
who were not at the farm
when the raid staged
across of the rest
of the United States.
So this is one of the posters that
he had made for publicity purposes
of course showing the need for
a national police force that was
in power to cross state lines
to track down criminals.
Keep in mind too that at the time
that this crime occurred, FBI agents
or bureau agents did not
have the power of arrest.
They had to bring in a local
police officer to do that.
They didn't carry weapons.
They were not trained
how to carry weapons.
They were basically a group of guys,
very similar to J. Edgar Hoover.
They were lawyers or
accountants and they would go
in to assist local law enforcement
as they built their case.
So suddenly, Hoover finds himself
up against these gun coating,
toting criminals and he
really doesn't have much
of a force to go after them.
He looks around his country
offices and decides that of the 300
or more agents that he's got, maybe
12, 15 have the kind of training
and skills to chase down people
like John Dillinger
and Machine Gun Kelly.
So he assembles that
force to go after Kelly.
Those are some of the
places they went.
And so they created this
nice graphic about the number
of kidnappings that were
going on around the world.
And again, gets that out in
the press, builds up the sense
of paranoia over kidnapping scourge.
This is one of Hoover's
key agents, Melvin Purvis,
you've probably heard of him.
He was like Hoover, a trained
lawyer, an investigator
with no military training,
no police training.
But when Hoover gets his assignment,
he takes Purvis and sends him
to run the Chicago office which is
probably the toughest office the FBI
has to deal with.
He subsequently fails to find
Kelly when he makes his trip
through Chicago, that's
another story.
Eventually though they do
track him down in his home town
of Memphis Tennessee after
about 8 weeks on the road.
This is him being led off in chains.
The story about his capture
is interesting as well.
Hoover of course as this coverage
is going on over the weeks and weeks
and weeks of their, that
they're chasing Hoover,
it's making national headlines
around the country and in Europe.
And but it's always Kelly gets
away again, Kelly gets away again.
In a lot of cases the press was
ahead of the bureau's agents.
When Kelly was hiding out in
Mississippi, he's just checked
into his hotel room and he walks
out and a newsboy walks by saying,
Kelly thought to be in Mississippi.
He turns around, goes
back in, checks out,
gets in his car, takes
off to Louisiana.
So after, so he and Kathryn had
been running around the country
for a couple of months trying
to stay away from the law.
They end up back in
Mississippi, I'm sorry yeah,
in Tennessee, in Memphis.
And the bureau finds out that he's
there and they put a raid together
and they come in, I mean they're
armed up like the U.S. Army.
They open his front door,
they go searching his house.
Basically what they're finding
are a lot of empty liquor bottles
and glamorous Kathryn is
asleep in some silk pajamas.
And finally, Kelly walks out
of the bathroom, sees the,
all the guns pointed at him,
he drops his gun and says,
I wondered when you guys
were going to get here.
But of course that's not a
good enough story for the take
down of the most notorious
outlaw in the United States.
So when Hoover gets
done telling the story
and when his agents get done
explaining what happened,
it's that the agents come in, they
confront Kelly, he drops his gun,
he cowers in the corner and
says, don't shoot G Men,
that term he never used but
a term that Hoover liked.
And it became the moniker of the
FBI for the next 40 or more years.
They continued to tell
that story even
in their own publicity
materials a few years ago.
You can still find
it out their website.
But they've now begun
to recount a little bit
about what actually what
have happened there.
So they bring him to trial.
This is, this is Kathryn
and George in court.
Kathryn is looking very fashionable.
George is a little bit bloated
from two weeks of binge drinking
and the fact that he's been
recently pistol whipped by one
of the bureau's agents
right there in the courtroom
in full view of everybody.
You can see a little closer
there the knot on his forehead.
He was trying to defend
Kathryn's honor
after she slapped one
of Hoover's agents.
So the trial of course
makes for big news.
It's, it's the first federal trial
and one of the last to allow cameras
in the courtroom, motion
picture cameras.
There was a news reel made of this
trial that played in movie theaters
around the country for weeks.
People would stand up and
cheer when it was over.
Kelly, his wife, 11
other people involved
in the crime are successfully
convicted.
And they're all sentenced to life
in prison including Kathryn's mother
who really did nothing
more than make a meal
for Urschel when he was at the farm.
So building on this, on
this case, Homer Cummings
who was the attorney
general and Hoover decide
that the federal prison system
is just not strong enough
to hold these guys.
I mean most of them have broken
out of prison multiple times
by bribing guards, by
having people on the outside
and they were notoriously
porous prisons.
So they wanted to create something
which would be a penal colony
for what they call
the Irredeemables,
the worst of the worst.
People like George Kelly,
Al Capone and the rest
of the criminal class at the time.
And they do, they reopen what used
to be a military prison dating back
to the civil war on Alcatraz Island
and opened it with great fanfare.
George Kelly is in the initial class
going in and he will spend most
of the rest of his life there.
Kathryn is sent off
to a women's prison.
They conduct a long
time correspondence
with one another writing great
love letters back and forth.
One of the things that Kelly
really liked to do was write.
He was quite good at it.
He was not a criminal who was
kind of up from poverty class.
He wasn't a psychopath.
He was a pretty smart guy,
actually went to college
for one semester before
he flunked out.
He grew up in a middle
class family and really,
one of the interesting
understories in this is the romance
between Kathryn and George
because they're quite a couple
as you could imagine they had a lot
of really great family arguments.
[ Silence ]
After the trial, the
trial was presided in fact
by Charles Urschel's good
hunting partner and fishing buddy.
So a conviction was more or
less a foregone conclusion,
it only took one day in a matter
of hours to return the verdict.
Urschel never really wanted
any, any credit for this case
or any kind of publicity.
He didn't like being in the
limelight, being an oil man
and he tried to keep
his business secret.
So he basically fades
into the background.
And he instructs everyone
in his family
to take a similar position
with the press.
Don't talk to them, don't
get your name in the paper,
don't let them take your picture,
you could end up getting
kidnapped, who knows.
And so strong were his
admonitions that it's his children
that did pretty remarkable things
also stayed out of the limelight
and even when I'm was
researching this book and go back
and I'm talking
to his grandchildren,
they're even reluctant.
You know, they call him big
Charles and the admonitions
from Big Charles hold up even today.
Keep going, the wrong way.
A part of the publicity
that Hoover managed
to orchestrate was control
of the movie industry.
The movie, Public Enemy
starring James Cagney came
out in 1933 I believe.
And Cagney plays a Scarface,
Al Capone type criminal
and he's the hero of the story
and that just drove Hoover crazy.
And he complained to Hollywood,
he complained to the
production companies and he said,
you're glamourizing criminals.
You're making my job harder, you
should glamourize FBI agents.
And at the time they were getting a
lot of pressure from others as well
and they start their own code,
sort of a pre censorship code
and they say you can't make gangster
movies anymore unless you have an
FBI agent in them.
But the caveat was that if you
have an FBI agent in your movie,
J. Edgar Hoover gets
script approval.
So two years after
the kidnapping case,
G Men comes out starring James
Cagney, who is an FBI agent,
who successfully solves
a kidnapping case.
Machine Gun Kelly didn't
fare so well in Hollywood.
In 1958, Roger Corman, king of
the B moviemakers creates a movie
about Machine Gun Kelly
in which he's described
as a dangerous psychopath, machine
gun wielding hood, a cruel kidnapper
and establishes, it's so successful
that it established Charles
Bronson as a leading man.
That was his first role.
Meanwhile, George is
wasting away in Alcatraz.
Ultimately he's released
back Leavenworth
where he dies of a heart attack.
And that's pretty much
where the show ends.
I'd like to take your questions
at all if you have any.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
[ Silence ]
Yes.
>> Did his wife stay
married or did she?
>> Could you repeat the question?
>> So the question is whether
Kathryn stayed married to George.
And yes she did.
She spent most of her life,
she never admitted to anything.
And during the trial, she actually
got George to take the blame
for everything and to
say she wasn't involved.
Because she thought it would
be better if one of them were
out on the loose and not
both of them in prison.
And he agreed to do
that to his credit.
So he basically lied
about her involvement.
Nevertheless, she was
sentenced to life.
She's in prison in the late 40s
and ends up with a fellow prisoner,
a woman who is known as Axis
Sally, she was a propagandist
for the Japanese during
World War II.
And she had a real firebrand lawyer
who was trying to get her out.
Kathryn of course meets this
guy and enlists him in her cause
which he agrees to take because
he thinks the trial was a sham
and that the evidence was fabricated
and it was just a total circus
which to his credit it really was.
So he asks for a new trial
and the judge grants it.
However, the FBI refuses to
release any of its material.
Partly, it's thought because
they couldn't find it.
Partly, because they knew it
would prove Kathryn's case.
So with their refusal to cooperate,
the judge just releases
Kathryn and her mother.
And so she, she ends up working
as an accountant in what they used
to call a poor farm
where her mother lived.
And just took care of her
for the rest of her life.
>> Yes.
>> How much was the ransom
that was paid for Charles?
>> It was $200,000 which
was the largest amount paid
at that time depending on
how you calculate you know,
the inflation rate, that's between 7
and $14 million in
contemporary money.
>> Yes.
>> Didn't they have the death
penalty during that time?
I'm assuming that he killed
people in his pursuit.
>> Oh the question is didn't
they have the death penalty
and hadn't he killed people in
the process of robbing banks.
And that's the interest,
that's a great question.
That's the interesting
thing about George Kelly.
He didn't like gun play at all.
He was part of a system of
bank robbing which relied
on events planning and surprise
and the last thing he wanted
was attention or violence.
He preferred robbing
banks with a concealed 38.
And he was such a you know, charming
and outgoing fellow that he'd go
into the bank, the tellers
would think he was a customer.
He'd walk up to the tellers
and toss over his bags
and say, fill 'em up girls.
And they would comply
and usually he'd walk
out before the alarm went off.
But Kathryn, she Kathryn
was you know,
she wanted to see her
name in lights.
And she thought the way
she would get there was
by being married to
this famous gangster.
So she is the one that tried
to toughen up his reputation.
She bought him the machine
gun, bought it at a pawn shop
in Fort Worth, gave it to
him as a present and took him
down to the farm to try and
teach him how to use it.
And then she spent all of her days
trying to build up his reputation.
She'd go to speakeasys and taverns
in and around Dallas and Fort Worth.
And she'd talk about how good George
had gotten with the machine gun.
He could shoot walnuts
off a fence post.
He could write his name on
the side of a barn with it.
And all of that gossip kind of got
to the Fort Worth and Dallas police
who began to build a
profile of this guy
because they were suspicious
of him anyway.
Because it's a relatively
poor community at the time
and he's driving a 16 cylinder
Cadillac with white wall tires
and you know, customized features.
So it's that reputation
that Hoover's men pick up.
And so when the wanted poster
goes out for Kelly, he's described
as an expert machine gunner
and psychopathic killer.
But you're right, they did
not have a death penalty
for kidnapping at the time.
That's why they got it into
the subsequent crime bill
to make it such.
Yes sir.
>> Did he in fact ever kill anybody?
>> He's not known to
have killed anyone.
The only, the only violence he's,
well he certainly fired his gun
in anger a number of
times, but he's known only
to have wounded one bank guard who
surprised him during a robbery,
shot him in the shoulder.
>> How many banks did he rob?
>> How many banks?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know the total number
because he wasn't accused
of all of them.
He got away successfully most times.
But during the height of
his is about 1 a month.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yes.
>> What happened to Urschel?
>> What happened to
Big Charles Urschel?
He continued to run his oil company.
He spent a lot of time in the
safer environment of Europe.
He would tour Europe with his
wife for extended periods of time.
He collected art.
He bank rolled his
son's establishment
of a bioresearch mater, bioresearch
center in I think its San Antonio.
And he basically, you know,
lived out of the spotlight.
He too died of a heart
attack in 1972.
Yeah.
>> Did they ever get the money back?
>> They got, they got
all of Urschel's take.
So I'm sorry, they
got all of Kelly's.
Kelly had buried his money at
one of Kathryn's relative's farms
and subsequently they
found out where it was.
They went and dug it up.
His share was about $96,000.
They had some expenses they needed
to cover and Bates got the other 96.
They never found all of Bates'
money which is one reason
that Urschel would not cooperate
with parole for either of them.
He thought Bates knew where
the money was and he wanted
to get and he wanted it back.
Consequently, he didn't
let up on either of them.
And he thought Urschel could get,
he thought Kelly could get
the information from Bates
and Kelly refused to do it.
So it's still sitting
out there somewhere.
It's thought to be buried in
the Pacific Northwest somewhere.
Probably pretty well
decomposed by now.
Yes, yes.
>> I really enjoyed the book.
And I couldn't believe.
I'm really thinking
about Kelly here.
And the letter he wrote
from Alcatraz
to Attorney General Cummings about
this proposal that he be sent,
while he was serving his
sentence to some Pacific Island
to do meteorological research.
Do you want to mention that?
And it was a very literate letter.
It was really a nice letter.
He did, he was going crazy
in Alcatraz as anyone would
and he was desperate to get off and
so he writes to the attorney general
and he basically volunteers to take
any exploratory scientific mission
that the country might
think it needs.
He'll go to a deserted island in
the Pacific and track wind currents.
He'll go to Alaska and
study this or that.
He makes a number of
these proposals.
He's read about it in one
of the News Weeklys I think.
And of course prison officials
aren't used to getting these kinds
of letters nor is the
attorney general.
And so they just basically
scoffed at it
and denied the request of course.
But it was just, if further proof
of how ingenious the guy could be,
when he was first taken
into Alcatraz
of course they give
him psychological tests
and intelligence tests and he
scored at the top of all them.
He was not, he was deemed to
be a relatively normal guy.
Pretty smart.
He enrolled in correspondence
courses, at, from USC,
University of Southern California.
And he and Bates kind of
have a competition to see
who could do better in their classes
and so he tried to entertain himself
through advancement and education.
They were not allowed
to listen to the radio.
They had very limited
entertainment options.
At one point, in order to get
some music into the place,
they'd form a band and they
get permission to do this.
Al Capone plays the, I think he
played mandolin or the guitar.
Kelly played the drums.
And another notorious criminal,
Alvin Carpus played guitar as well.
Carpus committed two kidnappings
just before he was caught.
Carpus was Canadian, was later
released to a federal prison in,
out West, I think in
northern California
where he meets Charles Manson.
And Charles Manson wants him
to teach him how play
the guitar which he does.
[ Silence ]
Okay well thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Well thank you Joe.
As I said, it's a terrific book.
It was a pleasure to have you here.
When you go out, there's also
a notice about a talk we have
on Thursday, which is Richard
Moe, staying in the same era.
We'll talk about and sign his
book, Roosevelt's Second Act,
The Election of 1940
in the Politics of War.
And also there's a
survey if you get one
of the news releases using your cell
phone, you could fill out a form
which is how you first
learned about this program,
because we're now working
on that as a library.
But let's conclude with another
round of applause for Joe Urschel.
A wonderful presentation.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.